and welcome to punch-drunk sportswear
winners win it is our final episode of
2018 but that's right we got Christmas
next week in the New Year's after that
yeah thought you're gonna say the final
punch-drunk I was anyone so dammit
dammit
that'll be the next episode are we any
taking two weeks off or what are we
gonna do yeah okay I didn't tied up
we're gonna do a different day of the
week or so it's just like yeah holiday
time off dude I need to recharge you got
to work on your work on your [ __ ]
glutes me yeah I start toy box and again
tomorrow tomorrow I get back in oh
really
yeah I have to do something we're like
an immigrant is yelling at me to work
harder that's kind of where I have to do
for my workouts I can't just go to the
gym cuz also now or just try to hang out
where the hot chicks are why don't you
just get a housekeeper that you tell
you're gonna help that day and she'll
just yell at you some us are one of the
best looking man in comedy
stop it I mean like about me three
decades of stunning I mean a lot of
people call me Alyssa Milano of male
comics that they've been hot for many
decades many decades I mean you guys
thinking about she was smoking hot in
the 80s and she's still hot now right
would you say that yeah I ran into her
in person she's stunning stunning and
nothing both made out with Scott Baio so
there you go my favorite the only court
McGowan everybody yeah now Kourt you
have a comedy album out that just
dropped a little while ago called live
from Pearl Street live from Pearl Street
recorded live at the La Jolla comedy
store I can say that now right my first
album was there - yeah dude you used to
you and I back in the day when I was new
this has to be 2002 remember I had a
pickup truck yeah and we used to go down
and do moon doggies yes I remember moon
doggy smooth dogs I used to be a savage
down there yeah I used to go down there
bang waitresses in the [ __ ] bushes it
was great back when I was still [ __ ]
yeah when you had gluts when I had when
I dude I'm getting in shape we're gonna
be Jason Tebow uh I am going to be
tomorrow night Wednesday if you're
listening to this tonight if you're
listening to it tomorrow I'm at Sycamore
tavern for the big liar's club Christmas
party so yeah you're on that as well me
you Kate Quigley am I on that sure
aatrox that'd be fun and then of course
the 29th we have our big UFC viewing
party for UFC 232 I think yeah those are
awesome parties but yeah I had so much
fun at the last one I went to with you
guys yeah it's a blast yeah that's a big
one we got uh Russell Peters just
confirmed last night we got you we got
me we got Dennis Antonio Tony
Hinchcliffe Josh Martin I'm trying to
get a couple others secret court McGowan
come down I'll be I'll be down watching
the fight for a spot to show working out
one more name we'll see if he could pop
in but yeah dude so that's on the 29th
that'll be fun then I'm going to be what
I thought was at the Hollywood Bowl but
it turns out to be the Hollywood bowel I
don't think that's gonna be a good gig
so we're gonna have to get after my
booking agent lazy Rick then I'm doing
stand-up in an escape room so hopefully
I will be able to finish my set before
these idiots figure out how to get out
of the room so that's it where you guys
know that you could be part of the
torture of the xscape room or maybe I
want them to not to be able to find the
key which by the way was right under the
candles so if you want to just get the
[ __ ] out get the boiler where you gonna
be
I got I'm gonna be doing New Year's Eve
at the Comedy Store with Theo von Oh in
the main room do two shows one at 8:00
and I think one at 10:30 it'll be funny
just to see Theo von try to count down
from 3 3 5 yeah and then December 25th
26th 27th I'll be at the La Jolla Comedy
Store hello during the Farmers Insurance
golf tournament I do every year I do
this weekend
if you're a fan of golf or if you hate
golf but you like the way they dress or
you like all the hot chicks that hang
out at the golf tournaments they all
come down Ricky Fowler all the guys come
down to the shows yeah how could someone
hate golf
a lot of people hate golf how do you
hate it I they find it boring maybe you
paid 20 bucks to see the tiger and Phil
match and then it [ __ ] didn't work
like it I thought it was so boring for
the first 17 Golf is boring
I get that compared to all these
contacts well no way it's and you don't
really understand you have to play it to
like it but here here's the other side
of this that particular match okay do
you want to talk about this now it's got
400 dates to play no he's taking a month
off I did take the month off even though
he did put in Thai boxing starting
tomorrow Thai boxing Academy on I forget
what street it is but I'll be there I am
doing again the liar's club tomorrow
night at the Sycamore tavern the dojo
upstairs
it's the underground comedy club that's
actually upstairs than I am doing on the
29th you do UFC 232 show and that's it
for the year and then next year January
19th I just want to put this out I'm in
White Plains I am doing the naughty I'm
doing the just a night of me and some
[ __ ] dude it's so [ __ ] funny 19th in
White Plains New York in New Jersey my
power white power planners say something
planes New Jersey right now and if and
if nothing else just get a new credit
card why while you're there because
that's where all the credit card
companies are is it well Morris Plains
I mean Tiff's and mort's planes alright
that is January 19th
more's planes and our power with
centrally those dates are all at Sam
triplea.com grab those and most
importantly my two specials Armageddon
and zero Fox both live from the Viper
Room are available on vimeo vimeo.com v
IM
I'll just put in Sam Tripoli stand-up
specials the Viper Room any of those and
you will find them they are a dollar
ninety-nine to rent $2.99 to own you
will not beat that deal you watch an
hour and 15 minutes of comedy for four
dollars it's the cheap please support
the show when people do their own
specials man it's they're going out on
the limb okay they're putting out a lot
of money and putting going out on the
limb and it's just a great way to
support us even if you were out one or
you you buy one it really helps I'm not
looking to make money on it I'm looking
to cover most of back so that I could be
like okay this wasn't such a bad idea I
can do another one because if not you're
just waiting for these people like
Netflix or Comedy Central show time to
give you the green light and guess what
it doesn't happen for everybody and it
has nothing to do with funny the other
day Bryan Callen told me Netflix
wouldn't even look at his special are
you serious that dude is the funniest
guy [ __ ] no wow they would even look
at it really yeah the guy's got shooting
ABC they wouldn't even look at ya idiot
I put my special up against anybody's
dude let's bang da zero [ __ ] buddy good
one zero five zero [ __ ] in if you if
you if nothing else just buy it for the
title yeah it's the greatest title ever
I can say I own zero [ __ ] for 290 Tony
hey skills give me [ __ ] about my ah my
[ __ ] special
Lenny member yeah I'm waiting for them
to say some [ __ ] do I want flame throw
this poor young puppet on this [ __ ]
show so that's it man so uh thank you
it's been a great year ah it's been a
great year dude punch-drunk has had some
ups some downs it's some people quit
some people come back we have the
standard year standard you here's a
seven or six seven lucky seven so you're
a golfer I'm a golfer I caddied on the
PGA Tour ever like a good golf but you
don't just make it clear you are a
[ __ ] legit good golfer to be a caddy
right you can't be you don't have to be
a good golfer to be a cab you're a
scratch golfer I'm asked
golfer but but I've played golf since I
was 12 years old if you should have 84
you're pissed
oh I'll lose my fun yeah but who drives
around on the car go in and smash I go
in and just [ __ ] throat punch the
[ __ ] golf to put it in terms of
people listening to this podcast that
can golf or do fairly well in golf if
you shoot an 84 you're [ __ ] furious
where everybody else like calls their
friends would be like dude I was on fire
today yeah yeah I mean I don't get a
hold of it dude you my brother was is
like that dude my brother can kiss he
can golf and like you watch him swing
and it's just like you don't even barely
hear him hit the ball that's how that's
how sweet it as good of a player as I am
I am not even close and that's what's so
amazing to what those guys are you think
the differences between them and you
just more time well it's also young a
lot more time like these guys have been
playing since they were like 2 we have
in the world
yeah I mean it's like not necessarily
two weeks in the womb but I mean you've
got guys like like I'll give you a good
example like Rickie Fowler this is a kid
who's played since he was seven eight
years old
you know competitively competitive you
know since seven eight they've got these
Ajaj GA American Junior Golf
Association's these guys have played
Tiger Woods has played since he was you
know out of the womb but famously
yeah but I mean there's there's a whole
nother level to it and also you got to
realize that's what these guys do yeah
that's what they do
so they wake up in seven days a week 52
weeks a year they hit golf balls so they
know exactly they know if they hit a
9-iron it goes 151 and then if they move
this way it goes 152 and if they push
this way a science it's a science so the
thing is is it's like now they have to
do that under pressure under a shot with
the TV cameras rolling with thousands of
thousands of people standing around
around other skulls because some some no
not mentioning names DJ and
but I mean so there's like so there's a
whole nother level that comes with it
you know imagine you're standing on the
green and you're just trying to make a
putt to win sixteen dollars and you're
nervous about that but these guys are
nervous about [ __ ] you know they're
they're nervous in there to win a
million three and to get them you know a
masters bid or that you know whatever so
it's a it's another level it's just and
even even the guys there's even and
there's even levels above me that aren't
even close to pro levels you know I mean
there's there's just amazing there's
some I mean there's levels to the [ __ ]
there's levels and these guys and the
guys that play on tour are above million
times better than you can ever imagine
there's got a better life golfers or
tennis players I'm gonna say golfers but
I'll say this but I will say this though
that the less pressured life is a tennis
players life because of golfer every
year every year only the top 125 make it
into next year oh my god so every so
it's not way even more crazy than the
NBA the and crazy 420 players yeah yeah
but you also get a six year contract for
140 million dollars right this is like
the pool doesn't matter what you do
doesn't matter what you do in golf you
so it's like every year you're like hey
you know we got a audition to basically
be in the NBA every single year and if
you win a tournament you get a two-year
exemption so you have to win to get to
your data to a two-year exemption
running on black time she's always late
she doesn't give a [ __ ] it's a fight
nanny hi everybody welcome to the final
show of 2018 and at least she's
consistent
you know I can't wait to see how late
she shows up in 2019 that's this guy the
guy that shows up at 11:15 and then
walks his dog every [ __ ] are you arguing
that you're never late I'm not saying
never
lay I'm saying I'm not late all the time
Aaron Aaron no thoughts
I think he's not late all the time I'm
not oh yeah what's funny is I was like
super on time and then I took that as
like wow max needs a bath so like I'll
like get the bath ready and like change
a diaper and be like a nice helping max
is your female daughter yes and then
I'll hit her to Jeff so that's how I
took being on time is like let me waste
15 more minutes of the professionalism
so you said you're gonna win a
tournament we're talking about golf see
you got to win a tournament to get in
for the next two years but if you don't
win you've got to finish in the top 125
and the 125th player on tour makes six
hundred thousand that's what I was gonna
ask so it's like so and not only that
but in golf you have to cover all your
expenses so all your flights all your
hotels all your all your stuff all
that's paid for out of your own pocket
so oh really oh yeah so your caddies
everything everything is paid for out of
your own pocket so and the sponsorship
deals are not what they used to be I
mean only the top 25 players are really
making real sponsorship money the rest
of the guys make dick so it's what is
dick to you what's uh let's say a
hundred thousand for like you get a bag
or a hat you know that's like maybe a
hundred grand which is that's a lot of
dicks but but a hundred grand doesn't
cover only covers like five weeks of
travel you know it doesn't I mean you
got you've got thirty eight weeks of
[ __ ] tournament I guess you can stay
at a motel 6 when you're doing the piece
yeah you can't guys do I know guys do
caddies on the other hand we we room in
if we share a room and if anybody's
gotta pay for your own hotel we pay for
our own hotels our own travel or a union
is their golfing Union there is not a
golfing Union but the PGA Tour is owned
by the players so when you finish your
[ __ ] rain and you retire you make
good money the rest of your life
really oh [ __ ] yeah they make and that's
that's not even if you get on the
seniors tour how long do you have
to be in to give ownership I well if
you're a PGA Tour player you're an owner
so if you have a pleasure time well
getting your card one time now you
obviously it's like anything else you
get what you pay in you know if you're
if you're paying in over 15 years let's
say you're not a you're not a top 10
player but you've played on tour for 25
years you're gonna still have a great
retirement I remember there's this one
player a senior player named Jeff Sluman
who's who was not it not a huge not a
huge deal a Sluman can only be a golfer
or a baseball play exactly there's no
innings in the yeah and this guy told me
one time we were in an airport in
Chicago and he and he and he said that
you can actually take money out of your
retirement and you can invest it and he
invested it in the 80s and he goes you
know I play golf for fun now I don't
even have to work and I was like I love
this guy yeah but um but anyway so what
I was gonna get to was this whole Tiger
Phil thing and and the reason I think it
was so [ __ ] boring is both of these
guys played like [ __ ] and I was gonna
ask you about that guy they both play
terrible and and and you're never going
to have it took years of these guys
playing against each other years years
it's like the it's like Kobe jort or
like you know it's like magic and bird
it's like it took years of this
competition to build up to this one
match so there's nobody left
there's nobody now that like you talked
about you know we're talking about this
last night about you know this is great
for golf there's gonna be more of these
events where can you ever create this
event again you can't because it's there
it took years of this for it to get to
this one match and then this one match
they come out they go to one of the
greatest golf course who ever played my
life shadow Creek in Vegas yeah that's
[ __ ] believable and they go there and
it's [ __ ] boring they both play like
[ __ ] it was boring until about 16 it was
in and I and that's kind of when I tuned
in was like this 17th old Tiger had a
putt on 18 to win it
missed it was more exciting a tiger
versus fill or Tebow versus re T fo
versus re was way more exciting that was
exciting
that was and there was better there was
better commentating in in Tebow that was
the commentating of it was bad that
likes great I like was the commentating
was great I was I was really on par not
talking about the on the other one I
thought it was that we were killing I'm
surprised he didn't get offers yes about
last month I mean not lost money like
all these people rented it and then like
when none of us made a dollar on it like
rock where did all that money going
right I have no idea where the money
went
no we did it yeah we did all my life we
did it because I gave Jay
I gave Jay three hundred dollars to edit
all of it and it's like six and a half
hours yeah but down in 90 minutes checks
I would bust off part of checks but the
biggest problem is I literally never got
paid because we asked we asked you about
it and you and all three of us are like
we have no idea how we would even get
that much all right moving right along
but the whole thing is is like you saw
this thing go down and it's like Tiger
Woods Tiger Woods arguably you know all
these putts he's made all these chip-ins
he's done over his lifetime and he had
an 8-footer to win nine million dollars
yeah any [ __ ] missed it it's like
that was a soda emulation of a shitty
day where both of them played like [ __ ]
I mean [ __ ] they had a par 3 98 yards or
whatever it was they three times Tiger
missed the green twice yeah yeah that
was twice he missed them at the arcade
Green they kept doing that and cutting
new holes was it was it just because
that the whole headlights yeah because
it was a dark at that point yeah what
about it is they played a different hole
no so they kept going back and fill you
know there's Phil who's one of the
shittiest putters on the PGA Tour and
you know I missed a couple big pot yeah
I mean it's just like it was so boring
how much of that is back to your earlier
point that you were telling Sam is that
where how nervous it is I mean look me
and Ari we're playing
sitting there putting and playing in
games to be like just to have to watch
every episode of Whitney and you're
nervous Putman teeing off yeah this
guy's putting a ten-foot putt for nine
million dollars it makes it not only
that that's gotta be nerve-racking to
even these two guys yeah and I think
there's millions of people that are
watching it and it's [ __ ] you've
you've beaten Phil Mickelson over and
over and over again you know it's like
14 majors versus four or five whatever
it is 80 tournaments versus 40 yeah I
mean just he's it's crazy the difference
and here you've got a putt to go [ __ ]
you give me in it's their money so they
each put in four and a half minutes what
I was gonna ask you is there as well
yeah bouncer ship and all sort of [ __ ] I
mean yeah you know I mean did anybody
lose money probably not right but they
each put in but their four million
dollars of their they lost all the
pay-per-view money yeah that's true cuz
then he give it away they had to give it
away and it's like cuz I was like I was
play golf that day and I walked in the
clubhouse and they were like on 17 and I
was like how did you guys pay for this
thing go no it's free yeah and I go free
they go yeah they [ __ ] up after like
the third hole so they had to give it
away yeah it was free yeah
so anybody who paid the twenty bucks got
refunded there twenty bucks it you'll
never it'll never happen again
I don't think so I mean who are you
gonna get right but there's but four but
who cares it's like it there's no
there's not 20 years of rivalry built up
between these guys there's 20 years of
this what about Jon Daly versus Andy
Dick and I got to do a shot at heat all
yeah I mean I don't even know if Daly
could get through 18 holes without
[ __ ] Keeling over I probably know
that fat bass how about and then you
know and then Andy Dick would give him
mouth-to-mouth on his dick yeah I think
that would be cool now people pay a lot
of money for that I heard he's got a
[ __ ] hog that's the roof John Daly
yeah probably
hog that's what got big Hawk big hog
some of those big hog boys see hogs so
we got a couple people calling in today
we got Tommy
tohold calling in some [ __ ] went on with
his UFC with his YouTube channel and
then we got Chad zoom and zoom och
calling in about his new special his new
album a white guy called Chad that is
available now on iTunes he'll be calling
in and tell us begging us to buy his
special and we'll make him dance so a
couple of you buying what is going on
ah you are you a fancy football guy I
was a fantasy football guide you know I
remember when the NFL went on started
Thursday nights and they had the guy in
the blue suit with the red beard that
would come out and do all the the ads
and and had that weird speak you know he
was always like you know four goats and
you know if you're yeah so he had a
Twitter account and I actually wrote his
Twitter account I actually did his
Twitter account for the first year yeah
I know exactly what you're talking about
I actually did that for I mean from Game
of Thrones that guy
it looked they wanted it to be kinda
like that guy I did that for like I
start the NFL paid me pretty good money
you did it for a year right almost a
year yeah yeah I did it for like a
couple months yeah how come he won a
year and you want a couple months
because they can Nix the whole thing
yeah they nixed a Knicks talk entire
thing and it was so bad because you'd
have to like write all these like
[ __ ] dumb tweets and but you couldn't
get you couldn't really go into it you
couldn't be controversial yeah yeah a
real safe you had to be real safe and it
was just [ __ ] boring
super stoked and nobody asked me to do
anything that's really fun yeah nobody
asked me to do anything but I got to red
zone I got through nothing yeah but I
did but I saw I played fantasy football
that first year on the NFL Network won
my league
then you just retired on top I retired
on top I did play one year with Jay
Davis had a fantasy league and I came in
I think thorns Christian coke dealer he
does ever since he got his braces off I
don't you doesn't okay it looks more
like an opioid dealer than
when he had the braces I was like
definitely a coke deal I think I knew
you did that before I think we talked
about that yeah it was like it cuz I got
like they wanted they wanted this thing
and I was like you know what guys I go
I'm done this isn't this isn't fun
anymore I knew it wasn't gonna last
yeah I think there was somebody else
they did it too yeah they're like went
through people well I actually met I met
the guy and he was such a douche yeah
that I I met him at the Hollywood
Roosevelt went and we talked cuz and I
felt hired me when they first started
doing the ads and they go we know when
the season starts you're gonna be
writing the Twitter you guys should get
together and I was like this guy's such
a douche that it's like no wonder they
don't want him writing his own tweets
like he doesn't oh he couldn't have done
it he couldn't have done it
there's no way he could have done it but
yeah I'm not as I'm not as big and if I
don't like fantasy sports all that much
just because I kind of feel like now
you're like rooting for players and not
teams and that's it's not a different
puzzle and I think that it's like I
think you know I'm a Colts fan you know
dot you know ride or die Colts fan and
all you been a Colts fan you see this 15
years Wow really yeah what were you
before that I was kind of a Rams fan
because I lived in LA and I was like ant
get it okay right I won't get across the
[ __ ] lobby before he kills over yeah
let's get into this yeah you're totally
right so Kourt has a actual real Colts
Super Bowl ring with his name on it from
Jim Irsay who you're good friends with
the owner of the Colts yeah and he was
actually at the Super Bowl where Prince
did the halftime show which it hands
down as the greatest halftime show
there's never been a better it's top
five it's one two three four and five
like the second-best halftime show ever
is vitamist I think this is cool yeah
this is what this is a team ring this
isn't a player's ring right players
rings are bigger and
and way nicer but I mean but this is
perfect size hitting me love a perfect
size bull ring with your name on it
given to you by the Colts but we I went
to a lot of games that was 2005-2006 a
buddy of mine was Jim's assistant yeah I
became his assistant in 2002 and that's
how I got to know Jim we just play a lot
of golf together
see golf do you know his buddy yeah I
knew his buddy and and I got to know JIT
we used to play golf and so we'd play
golf and whenever Jim was in LA and he
used to come to LA a lot and we'd play
golf together and then he's like one
week he's like hey why don't you why
don't you come to Indy for a game I was
like I'd love to so then went to India
and started going to games he would fly
us out for the the football game so we'd
go to Indy with it private jet kind of
situation some helicopter sometimes I do
you want a helicopter in and everybody
complained in his neighborhood cuz he's
trying to do helicopter [ __ ] he what he
used to have a helicopter you doesn't
have a helicopter anymore but I was I
remember we went I'll never forget this
was the best time I what the I'm by the
way I'm poor so just so we're clear I am
poor I have friends who have money which
is even better because I have all I get
to enjoy some of it but I don't have the
responsibility yeah hey you're doing
fine
I went one time we went to we went to
meet Jim in Indianapolis because we were
all gonna go to the Tennessee game and
this is probably 2007 2006 and so we we
go to India I'm staying at his house we
play we we get on the his jet there's
eight of us and we all fly were flying
to Tennessee to play this place called
the honors course and then there was bad
weather so in the middle of this thing
they just turned the plane and we fly to
I think it was a lion we went to
Michigan and it was like beautiful it
was like you know September something we
fly to Michigan play golf
Friday Saturday wake up Sunday morning
fly to Nashville go to the Tennessee
game as soon as the game's over
get on the plane fly back Dean Annapolis
and I had a flight you know American
Airlines leaving on Monday morning to go
to
back to LA but I had to fly through
Dallas it was this big pain in the ass
and so we're in I'm asleep and he wakes
me up at like 6:30 he's like bro
just let's play does yeah he goes let's
play Crooked Stick today which is the
golf course he lives on in in
Indianapolis and I was like buddy I
would so love to play today but I have
work on Tuesday I have to be at work on
Tuesday and I go and there's only one
flight to gets me back to you know LA he
goes I'll fly you on my jet and I go
wake me up when you want to [ __ ] play
so we play Crooked Stick and I was with
another guy from LA right and we play
Kristina a lot of guys too and and so
and so we we end up as soon as we get
off our club or put our clubs in an SUV
that's waiting for us at the at the edge
of the 18th hole our bags are in the SUV
they drive us a half a mile there's a
helicopter waiting we get in a
helicopter we fly to the [ __ ] airport
we get it we we taxi billionaires get a
billionaire taxi F to the [ __ ]
airplane get off to get off the
helicopter walk on the airplane turn on
Monday Night Football and fly back just
me and this other guy and fly back to LA
watching Monday Night Football eating
steaks that was hands-down one of the
best days of my life has to be yeah I
mean one of the best days of my life
yeah you did that now is one of the best
days of my life just hearing every
single it was my hearing that story is
one of the best days of my life
yeah I have flown spirit since then just
so you know yeah and that is in its own
is like some weird kind of fear factors
yes [ __ ] up dude spirit how is how are
they allowed to operate the way they
operate if you ever did you ever go over
to Europe and fly there's an airline
over there called Ryanair it makes
spirit look like [ __ ] private planes
it is [ __ ] the seats are not for all
the seats aren't [ __ ] bolted down
some of them the separate like that dude
I'm telling you it's like the worst
[ __ ] airline you've ever been I mean
it is fill Airlines is like if
WorldStarHipHop ran a [ __ ] airline
that's what any airline would run
like nobody gives a [ __ ] everybody's got
attitude they're charging you up to ass
for everything like his fear could
figure out how to charge you for oxygen
they would charge you for oxygen yeah
I'm surprised you don't walk down the
aisle and have you chip in for gas yeah
it's just [ __ ] like yeah yeah yeah
gasoline I got a hat gas gas money he
just walked down I got ya and they go
well we in it and at that point they go
we don't take cash but we will so we do
have a square to slide your cars
unbelievable pieces of [ __ ] their seats
don't recline I would the sheets do not
why why what cause they can get it
leaving because they get in an extra row
of seats by not having the [ __ ] seats
recline do you realize that so they get
yeah dude I had to fly I was catting in
a tournament once in Puerto Rico and we
missed the cut I was caddying for
Parnevik back then we missed the cut and
used to back in you could call PGA Tour
and you go get me the cheapest flight
out of here okay and they would just
booked you a flight you know Pete they
had PGA Tour travel they would book you
a flight like it you know you missed the
cut at 4:00 and you're flying out at
7:00 and you got to get back to LA and
they go we found you a flight for like
400 bucks you know one way back I was
like [ __ ] booked it it was Spirit
Airlines and I [ __ ] got there well it
cost me another hundred bucks to bring
my [ __ ] bag on then it cost me
another $25 to pick my [ __ ] seat and
I was like well this is no longer a
cheap flight and then you get on the
flight the seats don't go back you're
like I got a fly from Puerto Rico to
Miami Miami to LA without her without a
seat that even goes back two inches it's
not like I'm gonna [ __ ] lie flat
anywhere but at least let it go back
somewhat right right just makes me angry
when I can't [ __ ] him I see I'm like
[ __ ] I'm like I'm gonna make the seat
go back I'll [ __ ] break this thing
you know I thought I could hate it dude
is so unnecessary and then what they try
to do is they purposely make their
website not work so you go there and
they try to jack you for more cash back
yeah and worked the website you're like
the web
didn't work and they're like well I
don't know what tell you well I could
tell you you're not going to charge me
more for this [ __ ] bag that's what
I'm gonna tell you I mean dude I'm ready
to start [ __ ] hate crimes going on at
these [ __ ] let me tell you that let
me tell you the secret to it no I you
can't do it with spirit but other
airlines here's this is the Popeyes
Chicken
yeah [ __ ] Airlines it's not even
Popeye they don't like em huh it's like
the John's market it's not even a
vaunted - John's you know it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's like the eggs just say just
say EGS it's not even real yeah you know
it's like [ __ ] up stuff but the the
secret to like if you're on like Delta
American any of these things what you do
is if you if they [ __ ] with you go on
Twitter and just tag them and just write
hateful [ __ ] on there then they'll go a
DMS and we'll help you solve this
promoters that Airbnb all the time -
John he's the king of that yeah I've
gotten like a hundred thousand extra
miles just by [ __ ] spirit not on
spirit but on American on Dell yeah like
I mean like I'll take a picture like I
remember once I was on a Delta flight
and the thing the the entertainment
thing just wasn't working so I was like
I took a picture of it and then tweeted
it and like thanks for all the great
[ __ ] movies Delta and they're like
DMUs will so you know so we can you know
and I DM and they're like we're so sorry
about it you know we'll give you you
know $50 credit you're like [ __ ] yeah
for sure dude oh it's so much and the
thing is is like and then you just go
nice on him then when you go into the
thing you go like me and rent is easy
we're on a flight once on American and
we sat on the tarmac for an hour after
we landed we sat for an hour waiting for
a gate that's the worst and they gave
him 25,000 miles and they gave me like
we will you know we just want to
apologize will you know we'll do
something I go hey you gave this guy
this why don't I get that and they're
like oh so sorry yeah we'll give you
that too and I was like [ __ ] yeah you
will and it's great because that's like
a free one-way flight yeah you know
that's a dick dawg I do it all yeah
that's what you got to do just following
him up blowing him up so I said when I
went to New York ah I got I found this
cheap-ass air B&B for like uh like I
like a 150 buggers so like a hundred
dollars yeah and I'm like she's like
check-in anytime you want
I'm like okay cool I'm I'm here wicked
early I have to check in now I'm like
yeah you said anytime ah
and then like I know she's like I'm
having mental health problems I have to
go to a hospital I have to cancel this
I'm like [ __ ] and now you're [ __ ] now
I'm [ __ ] so now I go I'm like [ __ ]
what's the hotel I'm staying at for the
Legion of the skank fest and I it was
like $300 that night because I they
wouldn't give me the skank fest deal
right so 300 bucks so I'm like [ __ ]
thank you Airbnb I got [ __ ] on
something like how much is it okay with
the dude credit me paint set me money to
pay for the room see that's that's solid
but you know also like you know it's
gonna get abused by people they're just
gonna be people just tweeting all the
time well no because it has to be it
would have to be a situation where the
they would have contacted the person and
they would have found out that you
didn't check in it's legit and it's like
listen they make so much [ __ ] money
that it's not a big deal for them to do
that which is you know what I I gotta
say a props to Airbnb because that's
someone who's taken care of [ __ ] a
[ __ ] they they're fixing a [ __ ] and
that's a good thing and you took it on
your own to go get a hotel they probably
would have put you in some shitty Airbnb
yeah you know instead you took it on
your own they're like well we don't need
it's not that they don't need the bad
press it's that you know they don't you
know now they're [ __ ] now you're gonna
start you know writing about this person
they don't need that [ __ ] on there you
know doesn't care [ __ ] Spirit
Airlines you'd be like dude there's no
toilet but you're like oh [ __ ]
you guys had me worried about this whole
spirit thing because I'm flying home for
the holidays but I'm on al-quaeda
Airlines and they don't even have seats
my tickets clearly says we will not be
landing this plane on the ground but
dude I was like 50 bucks
so yeah but there is luck on that when
go home I'm going to if something goes
wrong I'm definitely gonna tweet at
al-qaeda Airlines I'm very unhappy with
the service that was provided smack it
into the side of a building
Merry Christmas mom's you're so stupid
no I'll be out here oh okay ah so with
the originals news fantasy football and
I play Jason in both leagues and I
hammered him it's just what you're
talking about yeah this is what you want
to do right now brag about a non playoff
fantasy football game I haven't started
my lineup I haven't changed my lineup
since I was eliminated from now you care
about fantasy football
now that you're completely out of the
playoffs I'm the best man salacious the
best of the world that's what you're
bragging I'm the best of the world being
the guy that pays attention to fantasy
football
after he's eliminated dude I do I ever
knocked you out of the playoffs never
going I did the only reason you're not
in the playoffs is because I but [ __ ]
you the last time you look crazy this
week but I still beat you I didn't even
look how little this ow that's how I've
been out you're out even more now you're
out you're out you're the Cleveland
Browns of fantasy football duties just
not amount for a bisexual quarterback
he's killing it right now every
quarterback in the NFL is gay Hillary
Clinton told me that yeah they go both
ways
who do you think goes both Aaron Rodgers
for sure uh Baker Mayfield for sure who
I heard that they [ __ ] each other they
do and who's top they switch it out
who's Aaron Rodgers banging now he's
being in a hard day Danica Patrick yeah
oh really do you think she [ __ ] good
yes [ __ ] good do you think Liza
Schlesinger [ __ ] good where'd that come
from
because they have the same vibe those
two do they really oh yeah they're both
always angry I've never seen I've never
seen Danica Patrick speak I hope he
seems like a real tough person to be
around I'll see you next Tuesday am i
right guys
little-known
Danica Patrick drives the little dog in
the back of our car oh yeah well they
both like Schlesinger yeah that's the
ref when she drives her in Indy she
drives it at all Erin no I'm with the
whole time she dies but I'm like that of
course she makes Marc Ellis sit in the
backseat and hold her dog while she
races in the Indy 500 team gets it yeah
team I got it I just was good when you
explain your joke it means it's not good
[Laughter]
sorry I'm lost in court sighs oh yeah
that was that was good that was solid
this week has to be the championship in
the punch onclick who's in it
I mean clearly not either of us oh I'm
sure almost Chad sumac almost made it is
John Ian know he had such a good team
yeah it worked so hard to get that team
yeah cuz he cheated and lied to people
well this I'm trying to figure out
what's wrong with it okay so the
championship game is grits and gravy who
didn't even have that great of a team
anthe Johnson first escape
that's not Anthony Johnson I used to be
instantly jens's team oh so it's big big
t Dobbs yep mmm oh wow so the guy who
runs it team sucked still [ __ ] got it
and then I get two against uh against uh
I don't know the guys up paid in Long
okay good luck to you guys good luck to
you guys
I hope you guys do really well that just
went from right here to right down here
I like to I like the losers battle more
than I like what's going on I want to
give a shout out to people that you know
participated in our superb stomping
Jason Tebow yeah that's what we do yeah
we curb stomp that's right
did you see that viral video the Santa's
fighting in the street in New York yeah
there was the [ __ ] greatest like in
it and it's just like the the music
behind it was like I don't like a lot of
these stupid [ __ ] viral videos but
that was one that was like oh [ __ ] yeah
that's
well they're just whaling on it they're
all [ __ ] drunk Who am I to judge but
and they're all head locking each other
fat [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] throw
punches and just falling all over the
street no I watch videos I realize
nobody knows how to fight
it's amazing how nobody really knows how
to fight this select few of like boxers
MMA guys and a couple bad dudes from the
block yeah but for the most part nobody
knows how to fight do you yeah I think
that's changing your chick you're not
actually almost disagree yeah you're
probably nobody except 20 white girls
always think they can fight black chicks
and they just get their asses beat I
think the secret I think the secret to
fighting is get if you're not if you're
not a big [ __ ] you can throw
haymakers and you can really connect get
to the ground yeah if you can get to the
ground run well yeah I first of all if
you watch I think MMA and the popularity
of MMA has gotten almost to the opposite
of Sam's point because I think a lot of
videos now you see where there's like 15
year olds that really can fight yeah
like know how to stand know how to kick
know how to [ __ ] shoot and sprawl
I've seen more fights like pulley gets
what's coming to them and it's like some
dude that's like a blue belt and jujitsu
and just [ __ ] up some bully well the
worst thing now is nobody stops fights
back today you'd be a couple of shots
everyone stop it
yeah now we're gonna record this I saw I
remember once I was I was young I was I
was in high school and I went to this
concert
it was the Oklahoma jam at the [ __ ]
state fairgrounds there's no way that's
good yeah and the headliner was a band
called head east and the runner and the
band right before then was van Halen
oh wow this was like 19 directed 79 in
and there was this and it was back when
like jean shorts and [ __ ] feathered
earrings you know sure don't come back
and bad bad Mexican weed and there was
this little guy the skinny little [ __ ]
about five five who had on nothing but
jean shorts Jean cut-offs and highest
[ __ ] with long hair and a feather near
our show
I couldn't I can't remember that I just
I just remember this big dude was
[ __ ] pushing around the guys like
keep [ __ ] with me I'll take you out
don't those skinny guys ain't ya the
skinny guy goes keep [ __ ] with me I'll
take out this big dude was [ __ ] had on
like a jeans vast big big [ __ ] dude
and he kind of started he threw one
swing at the little guy the little guy
uppercut him and up ride was two punches
and the guy was laid out blood just
spurting from his face and I was like oh
yeah don't [ __ ] with the little guy no
the little munchkin do little munchkin
dudes those things like angry during a
month because they they've been they've
been going through this for a few years
the big fat guy just lays on something
and very few guys in the NFL I mean in
the NBA know how to fight they're all
just been the biggest guy around nobody
[ __ ] with them yeah like Shaq I mean he
knows how now cuz he's been boxing in
MMA
but like no no remember when they know I
mean they know how to hit their wives
but they don't know really how to hit it
there we go again with this what did the
wives do to deserve getting hit can't
stress out an office so I was sitting
there you know you look at like you so
we're gonna bring in our guest in a
couple minutes but we were you look at
like ESPN UFC just signed with the ESPN
and the ESPN just destroys everything
that they work with except the NBA and
you just think about like the NBA never
has any scandals on ESPN like like a
wife beating failing drug tests um
that's because that bar is so high now
like you know that they you know that
they do like the syrup that's like the
big thing in the NBA like they all drink
the codeine and [ __ ] juice you know
that's like it's ridiculous and now the
we'd like to fail a test now you have to
basically speech smoking a joint at a
brick you have to be smoking a joint
while you're pissing into the cup
because they don't the test okay with
that I'm okay with that I'm just saying
that it's like now that you don't hear
the scandals because you basically have
to like do a line shoot up and then
smoke a joint while you're taking a piss
test to fail a testing well that's the
thing with John Jones are like duty
who's high on coke it's a performance
hansung dry I'm like dude it's coke do
you know what you have to do you have to
literally be doing scoops in between
each round for it to do any kind of
[ __ ] help you out at all do trust me
yes there's no [ __ ] way and if
anything it it it dulls your your
reaction time yeah and all you want to
do is jerk off and bang chicks you know
and you really have to focus to jerk off
because you can't get hard right you
know there's nothing random about it
either like you look at like Eric Reid
by the way he's been randomly tested
seven times the [ __ ] Panthers signed
him six games ago
they want him right this guy's been
taking a knee all this time you're gonna
tell me he's been randomly selected
after so that's more than once a week
Eric Reid has had been randomly selected
out of all eleven hundred people in the
[ __ ] NFL to take a [ __ ] random
drug test yeah after two or three when
you'd be like no this guy's not a
problem
never piss dirty ever never piss dirty
ever took it knee yeah oh good you know
watch you take a knee he's wearing Colin
Kaepernick on his [ __ ] on his shoes
yeah I love our own Keith bring up Colin
Kaepernick he's never playing again he's
making too much money not playing or
lease enough money to be like oh but
that's at the point whether he'll play
it or whether he's not I think I think
it will play next year you do I do
somebody's can I think you will I
thought there's no it's it's calming
down it's calming down and I think it's
just it's it's calming down and it's
like you're not a chance to make a
roster next year I did you know that
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
because now you're gonna have this guy
Beto O'Rourke's gonna be running for
president have you ever seen his video
garbage better O'Rourke yeah oh [ __ ] you
dude he could even win his own his own
[ __ ]
against Ted Cruz yeah the Zodiac killer
the Zodiac killer but the whole reason
he didn't win is he didn't take the
Democratic support didn't take the PAC
money didn't take that you watch did you
ever see his video about kneeling watch
Beto Rourke about kneeling in the NFL
it's the greatest video you'll ever see
mm-hmm it's a guy who actually answers
the [ __ ] question right he answers
the question about kneeling in the NFL
and it's the greatest answer trumps
insane about it we couldn't be more
wrong
oh I want to see Bernie versus Trump in
a debate I think that'll be the best
[ __ ] your momís competition or
anybody who's not the Zodiac killer or a
[ __ ] you know for time I mean just I
mean Hillary Clinton give me a [ __ ]
break
thank you we don't want to talk about
that because people don't like that on
the show um are you UFC guy I love USC
so you watch all the fights I know I I'd
watch whenever I can but yeah I don't I
don't like by him and watch him but I
will watch and then I'll watch the
replays later for sure dude I love them
I uh
you know we're talking about UFC I've
said this before I think it's gonna blow
up in UFC's face signing a deal with Fah
with the ESPN I don't know why well uh
because the SPN just they love to
destroy their [ __ ] products when I
take it away from yox I mean take it'll
expose her Fox was perfect dude I
remember 2003 2004 I went to lie down
vs. Ortiz and and that was like that
that with you I was with the Maloofs oh
I saw them in Vegas yeah maybe you oh no
you couldn't go but you know I'll swing
back but I remember going to that fight
and like misses before the UFC had blown
it completely blown up yet it was yeah I
mean it was popular but it's like when
people think it's the golden years yeah
and it was like and I remember watching
that going this makes boxing just
irrelevant you know I like boxing I like
I but there's few BOTS there's not that
many great boxing matches but there's
almost every UFC guard that I believe
boxing's back I do too I thought the
last what was the last great the great
fight that I went to at the fury versus
um while there there was such a great
fun I was great I was such a great fight
but I'm saying but how many of those
have you seen in the last five years
no I mean you can count on one hand how
many great UFC fights do you see in a
night every [ __ ] one I mean if
there's 10 fights seven are great to
people I don't know in the UFC two
fighters I've never heard of is always a
better fight than two boxers I've never
that's a great point
I mean that is a great point yeah very
rarely will we see two boxers you don't
know and I have a crazy fight right
right right right
what's that all right joining us via the
power of skype he has been a MMA
household brand his YouTube channel is
some of the funniest MMA content out
there and we're gonna talk about the
controversy surrounding him please
welcome our returning champion Tommy
told how are you Tommy Tommy hang on I
got there you back there we go no
problem dude so Tommy ah so I go on
Twitter one day and everyone's freaking
out they demonetised
Tommy told chaos ensues what is go what
is going on dude well yeah I got be
monetized about a month ago but I didn't
tell anybody until I think last
Wednesday yeah man they they they
reviewed my channel and um well I kind
of actually about a year ago I was
almost fully be monetized anyway so
about a year ago they started doing this
like automatic not suitable for
advertisers system that they were using
and you know I say [ __ ] a lot on the
show
and I know I know
so most of my most of my [ __ ] would get
would get D monetize because that's what
I was only getting about and a 15% of my
video views monetized and that's where
of over a year so I've been kind of
dealing with it for a while but I wasn't
gonna change the show because I mean you
know if I stop cussing it's gonna be I
don't know yeah it's unbelievable that
you got you swearing is bad but people
playing video violent
Gamze is perfectly fine or twerking
videos and all that [ __ ] it is
ultimately gonna be the death of YouTube
if anything kills YouTube which i think
is gonna be really hard it is going to
be this weird kind of selective
censorship so so they were so because
you swore all your content is is your
content right you you do all the
voiceovers you do all the animation whoa
what's the issue there cuz you say the
f-word yeah so that was the first issue
right so like that's what was making it
pretty much not very profitable for the
last year but then just recently they
reviewed my channel and they de monetize
it for I guess unoriginal content which
I didn't really understand what that
meant I mean yeah I view my own [ __ ] I
make all the animations myself I've
voiced the whole show myself I mean
there are there are MMA YouTube channels
that literally just rip people's
podcasts like for 25 minutes and that
[ __ ] adds on them yeah I'm not really
sure what they're talking about there's
two accounts to take my other podcast
and just jacket and the only reason I
haven't complained is because for some
reason they get like a million views I'm
like okay that's great advertising for
my podcast I got to kind of let it roll
at this point every thumbnail you can
see me in every thumbnail and it's just
like this one's got a million view I
don't have any clogged [ __ ] does it
but he does it and it's like
un-fuckin'-believable to me Steve
Hofstetter is he running probably so now
what are you are you are you are you
still working with Fox now the UFC deal
with Fox is done which i think is a bad
move on UFC I think they should have
stayed with Fox and work to deal with
ESPN or just stay with spot with Fox I
think ESPN is going to blow up in their
face ESPN is disney ESPN loves to create
controversy the political correctness of
that channel and you're bringing in
dudes who get paid to get punched in the
face and kicked in the head you're
expecting them to be
outside the octagon I think your your
dancing with the devil are you moving to
ears piano are you still what's going on
with your shell so with the Fox stuff my
contract they had the option to pick me
up for another year but without a UFC
tonight because of the UFC moving to
ESPN they opted not to pick up for the
third year so I'm not on Fox anymore
either but I definitely will not be
moving to ESPN now I haven't talked to
anybody over there but I just have a
hunch because like you said they're
owned by Disney and being an animated
character myself that cost us a lot I
can't imagine that they're gonna want
Tommy toehold as a part of their their
lineup when they've got like [ __ ]
Disney Princesses and [ __ ] well what'd
they say Don no cussing well if they
said no cussing when you do our stuff
would you do it I mean I wouldn't do it
if the hell yeah I mean I think the
money are you kidding me [ __ ] yeah but I
mean I just can't imagine that they
would not that I've reached out to
anybody or anything but yeah I just I
figured okay you know Fox ended and this
is kind of the end of Tommy on
television but you know I still have a
lot going on in terms of I've got
sponsorship still that are helping out a
lot and and so it's not really I mean it
sucks that I lost Fox obviously and it
sucks that the channel has now been
dupatta ties but I'm still able to make
a living from this so at the moment I'm
okay if some other stuff drops out maybe
I'll be in trouble but I'm fortunate
enough to still be able to make a living
what do you think of the moves ESPN what
is the feeling around those that you
know that are associated with the UFC I
mean money-wise I'm sure it's great for
the people at the top ah
but as we've seen with the exception of
the NBA ESPN tends to tear down the
sports that they work with baseball
football they tend I mean they got rid
of hockey they wouldn't even play hockey
highlights for the longest time like I
think it's just a bad move man yeah I
don't think it's a really good fit
either I was actually a bit surprised
that ESPN made such a major play for him
and yeah I don't
picture working out too well to be quite
honest with you I don't know how long
the deal is I can't remember if it's uh
I don't think it's as long as the
beatbox deal was which was seven years
but uh yeah I have a feeling that this
is not gonna like you said they don't
really mix well together
mm eh you end up with a lot of nefarious
characters and and with the way that
that a Disney runs their company I'm
still I'm not gonna be too happy with a
lot of the headlines that get made and
under like you said ESPN you know they
can be contentious with other sports so
they're not gonna just tow the line and
say oh yeah this is what the UFC wants
us to say they're probably gonna end up
getting a budding head to fit so yeah I
also don't think it's a good idea are
they gonna do pay-per-view no they just
do like fight nights okay right so they
have to steal for fight nights and then
maybe on ABC which I think would be nuts
but they'll have a ABC UFC night which
would be a big one and the question is
does Rogan do that or do they bring in
their own guys and like right Rokan who
just doesn't give a [ __ ] because he's
got [ __ ] money
he's inca I mean is Rogan gonna [ __ ]
came down for this I mean brokenwood by
his own admission was banned for me as
p.m. for a short time because he had a
Houston Alexander kuo like he was a he's
like yeah dude Houston Alexander fights
like he walked in on you you raping his
mother and you're like ah you know uh
neither okay
Okamoto I mean Rogan didn't do Fox
lights no he would only do the big fight
ones the big Fox ones he would do I
remember I remember watching Fox 2005
night and they would give the you know
was a free night so it was rare they
would do it but I just don't understand
I just don't find ESPN I just I don't
get it Fox had it down they they did a
great job right in a great job I'm not
afraid of edginess they're not like they
don't seem to get into the whole like
let's rip this our partners apart like
ESPN loves to do and that was when they
were jogging hey I hate to tell
everybody unless it's a game watching
nobody watches ESPN the president just
came out and said it their political
correctness has destroyed their brand
nobody watches their talk
they're owned by Disney I mean Tommy you
should actually put your character in a
Nazi uniform and Disney will definitely
put you out have it have it [ __ ]
Cinderella yeah have ever nazi-like ever
chained up and sending her somewhere and
then now and then they'll they'll
definitely put your cartoon up well I
also want you can comment on that and
distance yourself Tommy tell us about
your patriotic yes I start a patreon up
for the for the show patreon.com slash
Tommy toehold there's three tiers one
five and ten dollar and yeah you know
I'm gonna give it a try with that and
and you know I'm still gonna put the
shows out there no matter what whether
I'm making much off it or not it's
already been a pretty good success Joe
retweeted that first episode and that
really helped a lot and yeah you know
it's rolling I think I had almost 100
already patron so have you tried a [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you calm I don't even know
that it okay it's it's after all these
quote-unquote
like they said it was conservatives but
it's really just truth P people in the
truth community got deep platformed from
the you from YouTube these people went
out and created a new their version of
YouTube which is called [ __ ] shoot and
it's brand new and it's meant to but
have no censorship and it's like where
all the people have gotten demonetized
and [ __ ] with on YouTube I've gone to
its [ __ ] shoot and yeah then you got
gap comm which is a social media that's
again meant to be for the people who've
been censored on either Twitter Facebook
Instagram or YouTube so those are
alternative now places and they're
growing now the numbers aren't what they
they are on YouTube obviously but like
and everybody hates them but else Jones
moved a lot of stuff there which brought
a lot of people over there I don't see a
lot of sports people so maybe you could
be the first but it is somewhere where
you can get a little following going
over there something to look into
yeah yeah definitely no I mean I look at
any and every possible revenue stream I
can so yeah definitely thank you for
it's [ __ ] ute dot-com so just look into
I post off all my other
cat stuff on there along with us along
with YouTube in case like YouTube just
decides to come in and get crazy so it's
uh what is it patreon.com Tommy toehold
yes correct
all right hey upcoming fights let's get
real quick
UFC 232 ah John Jones returns classic u
UFC move throw them right into the fire
they they have no clue of what I'll want
a tune-up fight is
I'll give Bell tours much better at that
they love throwing their stars in with
tomato cans to get it kind of ring rust
off
I thought throwing a Conor McGregor in
with um khabib was a dumb move a move
for their brand hurt their brand I think
he should have been fighting Anthony
Pettis once he gets that going then he
could take on khabib you showed Tony
Ferguson versus khabib if Tony loses it
doesn't hurt to UFC brand Conor losing I
feel hurts to UFC brand ah but John
Jones going in with Gustafson what's
your thoughts on that that was your
question
fight that is yeah you're right they're
throwing him right to the fire but John
Jones I think is back to partying again
so I think he's gonna kick the [ __ ] out
of Gustafson because I feel like the
problem he was having for a minute there
he was trying to get all clean and and
and do all these things that he wasn't
normally doing and it was throwing him
off but now that he's back to being John
Jones III think he's gonna kick the [ __ ]
out of Gustafson honestly even if it's a
little bit of ring rust at the early
parts of the fight he'll he'll adjust
before the fifth round and he'll another
decision
I hope um you don't like John Jones I'd
like to see him get beat yeah just like
he deserves to lose yeah I saw I think I
saw I saw Jon Jones dick punch Danish
Antonio one time at a [ __ ] at a party
it's fantastic I mean he dick punched
him it was awesome Jones
well they yeah and and he walked up to
him and they went to shake his hand and
he just doubled dick dick punch both of
them right there and they were so happy
and I was like how are you guys you just
got
punched guys yeah by the greatest ever
dude yeah it was awesome
see the problem is with John Jones is
they wanted to go full heel and it's
just like I don't know I like full heel
pays the bills in the UFC I like John
Jones I only think Tom the only thing
I'm concerned about is isn't a big fight
like that Russ can kill you in the first
two rounds because someone you know in
these kinds of fights
it's like someone gets one good one good
in your [ __ ] lights out that's very
true I mean look he took a huge shot
when he first came back and was rusty
against ovince st. Preux so it's
definitely possible and that could have
easily knocked him out so I mean it's
not that it can't happen I just I don't
know I don't know if I have that much
faith in Gustafson at this point his
career is he's been fighting all the
time - okay I mean we've seen what one
two fights out of him yeah maybe one I
think last was Anthony Johnson that's
about it he hasn't fought for a minute
he only fought once in 2016 and one to
2017 so Jones has got until the 29th
when does his next test so how hard can
it go I've been testing the [ __ ] out but
how hard can he can he just go really
hard for a couple of days like or can he
do the weigh-in and then just go [ __ ]
just gret just pound an 8-ball and
[ __ ] have a good night yeah well you
should lose be suspended for a party
truck that's my I know it sounds crazy
if you test positive for Coke you should
be like okay you're giving up half your
purse or something like that if you test
positive for steroids that's a totally
different discussion I agree I look is
not a performance dancing drug it's just
not but I think I think it's just one of
those things where there's a line drawn
and if you cross the line there's a rule
and it's like an if you break the
[ __ ] rule you broke the rule and I
think that's just the way it's gotta be
and it's the fact that it's illegal yeah
well there is that let's get into the
other fight does cite as anybody does
what's-her-face have a chance against
cyborg yes you do you think that
I just don't see it dude I just don't
Tommy what do you think his design yeah
I mean I there's no way I can ever pick
against Chris Eyeborg I mean she has
never had any trouble whatsoever and any
one of her fight uh you know it just
it's not gonna happen I think I'm a new
that's a great fighter but she is
officially a low-fiber guy I can't
imagine not a chance
cyborg doesn't get the win here she is
the Jim Brown Walt Wilt Chamberlain of
female MMA destroyed she's built Roy in
the future there will be many women
built like that's my opinion she's the
first of this build we've seen which is
like she's not a guy but she's got she's
built like uh like she's got the frame
of a dude and I'm not trying to be
disrespectful for her because I I'd hit
it you know just for the [ __ ] story
okay so I mean I think front door back
door whatever you gotta work on the
glutes before you go in there I think
she's been completely disrespected by
the UFC I think what we're seeing now is
why they never wanted her to fight
against a [ __ ] what's-her-face the
bit Rousey yeah Ronda Rousey because she
would have murder round Russia she would
have murdered her this woman is from the
future mean you could take cyborg
dropper 15 years from now and I still
think she could compete Ronda Rousey
reminds me a lot of Mike Tyson is sense
that it was a lot of bark and and it was
like people worked afraid we're afraid
of Ronda Rousey and she would come out
and close it in the first minute and and
that's in it but if you got past the
first 45 seconds you [ __ ] owned her
but I felt like Tyson had way more
skills like well yeah but fought against
legit legit box I I think it was years
we'll be like sheep for most of them
most of her but 13 wins she fought
against tae-bo people yeah but I don't
think Tyson had that the skills that as
much skills as you think cuz he when he
fought Holyfield it meant at Holyfield
just took took him and started boxing he
kicked his ass so it possible you know
Tommy ah
thank you for coming on we're sorry you
have to go through all this but you know
a man when they do this censorship stuff
they literally create their own
competition they're creating another
competition I hope that your patreon
does really well because your content is
[ __ ] hysterical it's so well-written
and I hope that people go to your and so
it's patreon.com backslash Tommy toehold
it's a dollar that's less than a slice
of pizza
that's less than a candy bar it's a
dollar to support a guy putting out
[ __ ] wonderful content man so we
appreciate you coming on I'm gonna go
subscribe to your stuff and dude we'll
talk again soon bud thank you so much
yeah I had a blast talking on the show
and I appreciate the plug man thank you
anytime buddy we'll talk to you soon
take care I still think if he if he puts
the guy in a Nazi uniform Disney picks
it up I would love that people there's
not enough good Nazi shows out right now
I mean there needs to be more just
saying Nazi the wacky Nazi who has more
TV shows in Hitler right now I watched
every document they're just documenting
history dogs there's a show about
Hitler's dogs
Hitler's weapons Hitler's army Hitler
here's like six [ __ ] shows off and
I'm not even doing a joke right now
Hitler that's like six different shows a
large History Channel let's trot you oh
yeah get in on the History Channel or so
Hitler has more shows than anybody in
this room people are there found maybe
he wasn't that wrong Wow whoa I mean
definitely didn't die he in Germany he
died in Argentina so maybe maybe he just
moved Argentine just started writing
scripts I guarantee you he's still alive
well how about that guy who says he's
Hitler he's like a hundred and eight
he's like I'm Hitler and just you know
she's cuz I didn't get along the Jews
people didn't like me come on it's a
misunderstanding I mean he got along
with the Jews they just didn't get along
with him well he was Jewish he was the
Rothschild hey is uh has a chat halted
okay let's see if Chad actually calls
and he's promoting this [ __ ] show ah
are you your football team is the Colts
they're doing okay oh wait
tell the other thing I wanted you to
talk about we need to go get back to it
is you were at that Prince halftime
Prince halftime show when it was raining
which is one of my all-time favorite
[ __ ] story it's one of the greatest
I've been to I've been to about seven
Super Bowls and not never have I like I
remember Katy Perry in Phoenix it was
like Oh somebody cut that wire I want to
see her fall in the middle of the field
you know she's flying across the field I
wanted to see someone cut one of those
wires and just see her [ __ ] go down
but the greatest ever is we were we went
to Miami for the Colts versus the Bears
2006 it was [ __ ] awesome but it was
cold and rainy in my n'cole Dinh Miami
it was like 50s you know the 50s or sick
and so me and a buddy of mine were we
had we got the Colt we went with with a
whole group of people all these people
went some people are all like somehow
related to the earth days yeah so
friends you know some people were bigger
celebrities and you know so they were in
the box there was you know there was
because they know I don't want to say
names but Jennifer Love Hewitt no but
like Mellencamp and you know some some
other you know people had sex at his
house was it sexy John Cougar Mountain
cats house yeah yeah you make this Hanny
yeah guys play music while you bang did
I made him sing that live anyway so all
that so a lot a lot of people the bigger
celebrities were in the box because it
was raining in the end they were really
cool because we were staying at this
hotel everybody was at the hotel and as
we're leaving they were like they had
gone out and bought ponchos so if you
were like so they gave everybody
Poncho's so me and my buddy we we go
down we're on the 40-yard line like 20
rows up perfect lievable seats that's
how I watch football the problem is it's
raining we're not on the covered part
we're on the expose but I got a poncho
but it's it's not kinda raining it's
[ __ ] raining there were two people in
front of us that had bears hats on there
were like bears heads and they look like
dead rat
they'll just melted you know like the
fake fur had all fallen off and so but
we were sitting there and the game was
it was such a great game it was like one
of the better Superbowl opening kickoff
was return first yeah he ran for back
for a touchdown Devin Hester I think
yeah after go to the Hall of Fame oh
absolutely
he's he the last the last of the last of
the punt returners kick returners
because they're eventually gonna is it
funny they're trying to face out the
foot part of football well you're gonna
have VIN Oteri's gonna go in the in the
Hall of Fame you don't have you know Pat
Mack if he might even get to that but if
it was an L upon runner back but I mean
he has every record in quarters and kick
returns but so um so anyways we're
watching this great game it's like it's
pouring rain we're we're wet I mean it's
like the poncho sucks yeah you know
we're [ __ ] time you just like work
we're [ __ ] wet and and and then we
kind of go you mean horny yeah literally
taking a shower in York literally taking
a shower and freezing our [ __ ] balls
off but the game was so good we were
into it so you know half time half time
comes we go in we grab a [ __ ] we grab
some [ __ ] hot chocolate we come back
down we're in our seats and they go
Prince you know this thing and Prince
comes out and it's [ __ ] pouring rain
and princes out there [ __ ] sing in
Purple Rain it went Herpa lights that
made it look so god man I'm cool
it was one of the coolest things now
this is does they worry about like
electric shock Lee they actually came to
him yeah that's a thing really came to
hick ever saw her as that yeah one of
the guys seen the president of the head
of the fun thing comes to him they go
listen we're really worried about what's
going on is there anything we can do and
he's like make it rain harder you know
yes he [ __ ] loved it they roll if
you've ever seen like when they do these
things they literally come out and they
the the gate the halftime stop you know
when the they blow the [ __ ] whistle
the teams go in the thing and thousands
of people start running on the field
setting up this huge Super Bowl
performance because it's for TV at
you know you know I write and then I
light up this [ __ ] stadium and this
guy comes out in [ __ ] jams he doesn't
do some [ __ ] Jam I've watched that
performance probably a hundred and fifty
times he [ __ ] rocked that [ __ ]
place and then and then I remember like
at we worse we were just losing our mind
and then somebody came down one of the
the assistants came down and it was like
four minutes into the third court and
they go hey do you guys want to go up in
the box and we're like [ __ ] it we made
it this far we're sticking it out
commend you for that yeah you know cuz
we ran on the field after the game we
was the greatest it was so much [ __ ]
fun there's a lot of people that if you
don't know if you have never seen the
performance if you listen to Joe
obviously listening to it look up on
YouTube there's a video of NFL Films did
a little like 20 minute documentary just
about Prince's performance in the rain
and how nervous everybody was about it
I'm here those two twin dance it was
that I'd like four inch heels he always
wears heels six inch heels it was unreal
there was you it was unreal and then I
remember going back we went back I think
it was 2009-2010 whatever can't remember
the year when they played the Saints in
the Superbowl and it was again in Miami
oh yeah and it was the who that played
it I was like yeah well you know dude if
you want go to Super Bowl uh
and you don't know a billionaire owner
you could use seeking seeking for all of
your ticketing needs everybody that's
right
our sponsors are good friends for the
last year and a half
SeatGeek use the promo code punch 25
right 20 punch drunk punch drunk 25 up
punch - hey Chad Chad
[Music]
so loud ah that was annoying on the
subway I'm when I'm doing my read my
really good read I was crushing that
reading not crushing the read I was
total wrong from Oh God I was are two
times I was already on seek equal
killers
looking for ticket I know musica
punch-drunk I use crushing that read and
that gets you $20 off your first ticket
all tickets are guaranteed you're not
gonna get shams it's a great app to have
on your phone and you can look up all it
literally knows where you're at and
it'll tell you all the cool events that
are around you if you want to just
search for that if you don't even know
what you want to do let's say you have
no idea what you want to do tomorrow
open up the app and it'll tell you all
the things that are on there and it'll
it'll rate the tickets for you so I'm
excited because Bellator is coming right
Bellator is coming and we're gonna be
able to see phaidor fight at the
forearms guess who where I'm gonna be
going for my tickets Sikhi dunno if I
could watch that I can't I'm sick of
those old fighters it's getting nice
ghosts listen I saw Patrick you gonna
watch him go yeah I saw I saw Patrick
Ewing as a supersonic he's my favorite
player of all time if I didn't get to
see him as super SOT see him play
Michael Jordan I got to see his a
washing wizard I know you got to see him
all the time as a bowl I never got
seemed except for as a Washington was it
I need to see these things
hmm I need to see these guys go off
greatness yeah see geeks got they got
Rose Bowl tickets yeah I got Rose Bowl
tickets a key Ellie I got used them for
LA Kings tickets what's [ __ ] fan town
yeah that's great it's good it literally
will tell you like don't buy this ticket
that's a ripoff buy this one yeah yeah
good stuff man should we try to give
Chad another chance
hello Chad are you there yes can you
hear me sorry I was gonna train yes we
know it sounds like you're getting
pelted by I told you I know subway so
yeah we thought we were on trading
spotty and we were doing heroin as the
trains came by
I'm Chad sumachs new album a white guy
named Chad
is out now on on iTunes now the whole
thing is this Chad wants to be top 10 on
iTunes so uh I would love because we all
love Chad coming on except for that time
where he was saying the N word a lot on
the show
besides that we really loved him on the
show Chad why should they buy your album
well first of all I want to thank the
punch trucks fans for buying the album
I'm currently at a number a number 11 on
the chart come on yes I just need one
more to get over even if you share it
the proceeds go to me which is a great
foundation it's no Armageddon but it's a
good album you'll enjoy it Chad so tell
them about this album why is it personal
to you this album what why does this
make this help them different than all
the other comedy rock that's out there
right now well it's the 15th anniversary
of skanks for the memories by the great
Dave Attell you know did you know that I
did I did and I thought I thought maybe
it's time for a new instant classic
so I released a white guy named Chad all
right how many times on the egged sumac
Jason Tebow here big fan how many times
in his album do you drop the n-word on
that that's all on you buddy that's all
on you um that's all on you
Oh Chad how long is this elbow I don't
know I kind of did what you did with
your your double your double special
it's like 37 minutes but it's only like
$6.99 oh that's not bad at all $6.99
yeah so Chad what are some of the jokes
on there that people are gonna love like
is your Dennis Rodman's story on there
no it's my last album but I do a great
hot pocket I really enjoy that one okay
so all right
Chad I'm trying to sell I'm trying to be
seeing this [ __ ] on them like you guys
don't work unless you're like [ __ ]
[Laughter]
Chad you're two minutes away from Sam
promoting his album again not get a
better sound system for this phone oh my
god
now your shitty on all things comedy
it's a terrible phone line it's always
so hard to hear you guys okay Chad we're
trying to help you did he just hang up
yeah
so go let's help Chad we love Chad
Chad's had a hard life
yeah he's [ __ ] riding trains for
God's sake this poor guy is driving it
yeah conductor knows dad's a coke dealer
oh yeah I mean a lot of shits going on
he uh you know he told me he was cuz I
was just talking to her before the show
he goes you know I almost named my album
[ __ ] black people and I was like well
I'm glad you didn't bro dude I don't
really like people I love black people
that's how you were saying last night I
was honest last night I love black
people a lot okay a whole lot okay oh
yes of course I wear proudly okay bra
you should sell it um one thing another
thing I wanted to talk about that you
definitely apply state but our state
back to Earth Day and hanging out with
somebody that rich either you mentioned
this or maybe Andrew Siciliano had
mentioned it that he has a guide that's
just responsible for tipping well no not
necessarily I mean yes yes people that
work from just like anybody does I have
nobody who works for me know if you have
it not if you're if you're if you're
someone who like I I know I know another
buddy mine and that's like very well-off
and he has someone who sets up his
travel so like that like they do like
they go they go and make sure that
everything's and there are the people
that take care of people because they
are the ones that are making the
reservations
going to make sure the rooms ready you
know they're doing all those they're the
ones yeah because we're that rich you
have to tip well or your everybody just
thinks you're an [ __ ] when it's
publicly known that you're super rich
well I'm just gonna say this though is
is in all the years that I've known Jim
he is still one of the most
down-to-earth sounds like it he is
beating off chicks a chicks just like
he's been in a long-term relationship
for he's he's not that guy he's not a
he's not a guy that goes out and love it
and chases [ __ ] and does that he is a
family dude he's got roses Rogen's like
he's got three wonderful daughters that
are all married have kids he's a grant
he's like he's a family guy he's one of
the nicest guys I've ever met in my life
just generous sweet nice people
like genuinely cares about other people
I mean that that's one of the things
that it's like you know I remember like
being around that like you know you go
to the games you're out it's a family
man it's like nice people it's not a
bunch of celebrities that I mean he has
friends that are celebrities but they're
all like they're all they're all nice
people you know they're not [ __ ]
they're nice people and it's not like
you know it's not a you know you're a
celebrity so we treat you better than
other people
you're just you know everybody's
together everybody's on the same bus I'm
right on the bus with Stephen Stills and
the guy from REM I mean we're all going
to the same thing you and REM on the
same bus yeah how come you didn't open
with that story I don't know because I
don't know about I don't know about how
you feel about REM I mean Michael Stipe
laughs once it wasn't Michael Stipe oh
he wasn't that wasn't him wasn't Michael
Stipe okay yeah what happened to that
band what happened to the Fine Young
Cannibals dude they were crushing it and
then they just went away what happened
to Supertramp what happened to
Supertramp
yeah well happened that one Australian
band what happened to the Big Bopper
what happened to Wolfmother that was a
great paper crushing it then gone yet I
don't know
the rack and Tours are coming back
though oh really yeah
why had the white stripes you know Megan
what your whatever names whatever happen
to Selena well I haven't heard from that
[ __ ] in a while
have you seen Celine Dion's new kids
[ __ ] have you seen Celine Dion
Sanders new clothing line Celine Dion
[ __ ] kids now she's creepy as I said
while he cut me off cuz I was gonna say
Celine Dion's new kids line it's creepy
as [ __ ] kids line of clothing yeah it's
like hey every but all the kids dressed
the same girl this red jumpsuit three
handsome whatnot he says New World Order
on it Oh [ __ ] weird [ __ ] we met
her husband when she was 12 so yeah
she's a [ __ ] I played I played golf
to her husband Rene before what do you
go hey let's go [ __ ] some high school
chicks no he was a nice he was a nice
dude yeah yeah we played golf with this
guy then invented the camera that they
use on World Poker Tour you know where
they show the car the card in the delay
or they do the thing it's the whole
cards the whole cannon yeah and that guy
was that guy was [ __ ] he was loaded
man the guy on my podcast of the day his
friend's dad is like the poppers King do
you know poppers are for like gay guys
do poppers they're like sniff drugs and
he's like the king of that world imagine
me math the kid horrible title the king
of gay sex drugs imagine that damn well
he's probably richest [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I
met it talking about meeting like I met
this guy once that invented the the
bolts that they use in airplanes that
Boeing uses to like hold all the it's
like talk about making some money i that
invented this you can't monetize it
where's this patreon page yeah let me
show you how to do this correctly you
don't you don't cup it this way you got
to cover this way for a dollar
ninety-nine you can learn how to test
your breath we're the old men at The
Comedy Store now we are we're the old
men
yeah I'm probably well I don't know
there's probably well Argus is older
than me arguing Erin Merryn meirin's
probably Logan's older than you you know
rich or - but all wealth is Rogan you
know well sit there there's not a lot
bill birnes 50 something go burst 50
Ferris Barris is a thousand Baris is
like he went to high school with
McDonough yeah so Holden's McDonough
she's 56 or something like that yeah
yeah she's older is that what you're
supposed to do fight nanny when Johnny's
not here look up [ __ ] I was looking up
Celine Dion's line which isn't that
creepy oh wow 60 years old I thought it
was gonna be crazy like we're boys what
[ __ ] pictures of glory holes on there
[ __ ] hole non-binary stuff does upset
me so I was about to get upset with you
but I feel really not you like stars
it's like yeah boy or girl I feel like
you shouldn't be able to wear it you
shouldn't be able to wear clothes until
you're 12 until you choose your gender
cuz then we can decide who's gonna get
hot and who's not gonna get are we
bringing up your upbringing were you hot
or not yeah that's that's what the
clothing line should be for kids hot or
not both your mom's like no we're
neutral tassels not 10 year olds BAM at
that that is going to get you in trouble
you make that bet a bet DSi bet DSi for
all up you're betting needs that's right
go to Betty sighs use the promo code
punch 25 and you get $25 betting cash
and they will match any deposit up to
$500 a but in 500 bucks and guess what
now you got a thousand and $25 thousand
25 that's the [ __ ] dude you made bet you
do parlay SH you know I do those parlays
and I almost make no money because I
miss my water really all you got to do
in a parlay is hit it once or twice in a
year and it'll cover you all the Saleen
be on kids clothes you wore
sponsored by Celine Dion's kids clothes
possibly if you stop saying if you stop
saying you stop saying that she [ __ ]
kids
I didn't say closer for you to get [ __ ]
I think you said her closer for kids to
look super [ __ ] no I did not say
that yes I'm really against all that did
thank God that DSi was around that read
because they don't give a [ __ ] we can
run I would love to get like children's
clothing though comedy can we get some
cake close up in this [ __ ]
you're the only one in here that has
kids wait till we start spraying people
down and then we all have kids that's
not right Apple go and care don't you
spray penetrate haven't sprayed in a hot
minute like what does that mean I don't
speak black speak what does that mean
that since this morning I was gonna say
for you like a month yeah aha minute and
don't forget about our other new
sponsors Spirit Airlines I don't want to
fly safe and have a wonderful experience
while in the air don't be hard airlines
thanks spirit are you basketball fan at
all you know I don't I don't hate black
people I just don't find the NBA it's
not Chad sumac over here I don't find
him being interesting anymore
I don't cuz there's no more teams its
players there's just not they're not
team it's kind of changing but I get
what you're saying but you love hockey
though I love hawk you go to you're a
big Kings fan I'm a huge Joe Barton Joe
Barton's gotten in your skull got you
this guy I love have you always liked
the Kings or did you start liking them
when they started why I always make the
case cuz I moved to LA in 84 mm-hmm and
when I feel the glory years folk was
flowing yeah nobody had AIDS yet well
some people a lot of people just didn't
tell you they nobody important but only
gays had AIDS only gay yeah I remember
back in the good old days yeah we yeah
yeah but the great thing was is all my
my high school college days and there
was no AIDS so that was fantastic great
times didn't have excuse no just like
plug away yeah you know get tested you
don't have AIDS yeah and an abortion was
only a hundred I said that you know
abortions were cheap you know it was
like fantastic
it was great I think I have abortions on
Groupon yeah for that [ __ ] you wouldn't
want a Groupon abortion because it might
not it work you get what I give you
yeah Groupon abortion is you stand at
the top of the stairs you know and they
just shove you oh you prefer you
absolutely and you're and you would pay
me to do it I'll do it for free I'll do
for free not fun
you need have to be for fun it could be
for that fall way but it would be
[ __ ] super fun I mean there's no way
that's not fun how many hockey games you
go to oh I got a lot I probably go to 20
I probably go to 20 a year isn't amazing
how many Mexicans love hockey you know
it's it's just it's a great it their
hockey fans are fantastic they're
wonderful people
it's hockey fans are great because
you'll still have like you'll still have
a ton of the opponent's fans in the
stands and they don't throw punches
remember we wish we went to the the Rams
game oh yeah they got that dumb ass got
into a fight right yeah it was like all
over the place it's like there's always
a fight in in or several fight yeah but
that one - Dodgers playoff game - Dodger
fans who look exactly alike
we're fighting identical Mexicans we're
gonna start fighting each other Wow it's
so weird it's like you're on the same
team dude people stab each other Dodger
games yeah but it's but hockey hockey is
just like it's some there's something I
love the sport if you've never been to a
hockey game you are missing the greatest
live game there is
yeah I agree hockey is probably the most
fun sport to watch live it is well there
let me let me rephrase that
it's the biggest please it the biggest
difference from the watching on
television experience to the live
experience there's the biggest
difference in that and I think that I
think that changes salsa football I
don't like football live there's like
stop go stop go let's go if you add
40-yard line
it's difficult to follow a football game
when you're when you're I mean you can
watch it at the game but if you're not
sitting somewhere where you've got a TV
screen where you can watch the replay
you miss out on a ton of
[ __ ] and it's like hockey it's like
there's something about it being live
that's like you get to see the whole
rink because there's no way the cameras
they just don't I can't figure out why
they haven't figured that out yet how to
cover because when you see that the
changes that happening cuz they're
changing all the time and you get to see
the place develop and you watch the
whole thing happen
it's [ __ ] awesome mm-hmm and the hits
that off [ __ ] it's unbelievable it's
such a great sport it's and regarded
live and we are [ __ ] bottom of the
barrel this year yeah yeah fire sale
please get rid of some [ __ ] get
rid of quick yep get rid of everybody
get rid of quick get rid of Toffoli get
rid of you know I don't when in you
should be losing yeah well I think
there's gonna be a big trade that's
gonna happen trade deadline they're
gonna get rid of some really big names
and people are gonna be all up in arms
but it's a young man's it's a fast game
now and if you ain't fast get the [ __ ]
out there's no more goons in hockey
there's you know are you sad about that
or do you like it ah they're still
fighting you know my say I have to yeah
my buddy Nate Thompson took a guy down
the other night and I loved it it was
great but it still needs to be there and
it's is still there and it still happens
but there's just not a guy coming out
there to you know that you see the guy
skate and you go well you know what's
gonna happen now like because he comes
on the ice and it's just this slow big
[ __ ] monster just skating over to some
guy he's like oh [ __ ] here we go we got
a fight now fighting in you you ever
watch hockey yeah you would like it oh
it's it's it's the greatest just like
hockey no you got to realize you got
guys like oh yeah dudes you got guys
that are six for 240 skating as fast as
they possibly eating ice skating with
pads on [ __ ] hammering dudes with and
[ __ ] [ __ ] I mean it is the most
violent fun fast sport you've ever seen
and they're not [ __ ] they're not
[ __ ] you'll see a guy [ __ ] I saw a
guy
he took a puck to the face on a slap
shot [ __ ] fell on the ice think that
he gets up they have to come out put a
towel on his face they carry him off
there over there scooped in the blood
off the [ __ ] ice he goes in he's in
the next shift they [ __ ] stitch him up
and throw him in the night shift yeah
those are men my brother ran a hotel in
Arizona and he will he was running the
valet and housekey housekeeping and he
said by far the nicest ass late yeah
we're the hockey players yeah the worst
he said were the New York Knicks and
Barry bond Barry Bonds was known for
being a prick
yeah yeah yeah I've never met a person
he was you never heard a good story
about you see these guys like I mean in
the NBA they they they were wearing
masks cuz they got an elbow in the face
and they fall down and they they [ __ ]
run off
I mean hockey players they don't most no
none of them have a full set of teeth
they actually have a dentist that
travels because they got to fix these
guys [ __ ] face on a regular base I
respect that
yeah they're there my man back there men
hey Aaron doesn't upset you we've talked
a [ __ ] ton of hockey and a [ __ ] ton of
golf and no major league baseball we've
talked more there's hockey and no
baseball there's no baseball well I mean
the Dodgers are might be going after
Harper I'm sure there's no baseball
right now I'm still basking in the glory
of getting Paul Goldschmidt I'll be fine
okay until April Erin are you still
getting a divorce no maybe we should get
a divorce attorney as a sponsor and
that'll really help out Erin yeah use
the cony
Erin's wife left him and that gives you
20% off of your next divorce
you're just so rude so real what are you
guys all doing for the holidays Happy
Holidays saw punch-drunk fans by the way
what it would be I'll be in Oklahoma Oh
going back you do need spots there
Gockel son where where do you great
Indian casinos out there to do big of a
the longest set I've ever done to Nath
hours was at a [ __ ] toga party two
days ago last time I last time I did a
spot in Oklahoma was like 12 years ago
with dice
at some fire Lake casino yeah that's why
I did fire lake yeah and they'd like
okay how much time they watch you I go
how much time you want me to do is like
I don't know just go I'm like well who's
opening I go they're like there's no
openers you see I go how long do you
want the show to be he goes well at
least two hours
I go wow I'm like okay and then I just
went up and they just didn't give a [ __ ]
they just want somebody to talk to them
for to nap hours I'm like I don't know
how Ruffy may doesn't solve if I would
have been ever won that's why he's dead
if you would have been in cargo shorts
and Crocs you would have just gotten a
standing out that [ __ ] place man I
can't I'm going three days in and out
what about you they need anybody dude
come on court your sonde City I'm going
to see family I'm not going to worry
they're a local comedy club there is a
local comedy club there but it is it's
like Christian like you like they
wouldn't it's like the comedy magic
they're not Jesus yeah they're jokes for
Jesus Jesus say God dude
Jesus is a [ __ ] [ __ ] brought him up
right right well so much for having any
sponsors in 2018 Bob Spirit Airlines are
there any good golf courses in Oklahoma
yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah man one of the greatest
golf courses there is an Oklahoma State
is Karsten Creek why don't you do
stand-up at golf courses I told you to
do that I'm trying buddy I'm doing it at
La Jolla Comedy Store the week of the
farmers open buddy you should just go
like cuz they have these entertainment
[ __ ] budgets be like hey dude dude I
scratched off I've done not as much fun
as you think oh I bet that would be
terrorist want cash homie I know I know
but straight cash I like to enjoy cash
okay I I don't want I you know no no how
does that work when you caddy like purse
wise you get you get you 5% if you make
the cut you get 7% if it's a top ten and
you get 10% of a win and now I bring my
total purse of the of what your guy made
okay your guy makes let's say for
example your jordan Spieth county you're
making a lot of money absolutely and so
you get a salary though you get a you
get a salary every week so your salary
could be you know I don't know what he
pays his guy but it's good you know yeah
but you know then you get 5% and I don't
know but the general rule is for
Jennifer for normal caddies it's 5% of
the purse if they if you make the cut
seven percent top ten and ten percent of
the win so if a guy makes a million won
in winning the tournament he gets a
hundred grand one hundred and ten
thousand dollars okay you know plus his
weekly salary how back-breaking is that
gig it's not as bad like like during the
round during the competition it's not
bad at all because you're basically you
know you walk and then you stop you walk
and you stop it's not what's an average
bad way
50 plus pounds uh you're walking around
well dude you're carrying like I
remember and when I carry the best water
plus oh yeah like for Parnevik like he
had need so like not only that he's got
his wallet his watches rental car keys
his [ __ ] you've got bananas you gotta
borrow yeah you got his rain gear you
got a dozen golf balls you got two
bottles of water you've got another
bottle of his whatever protein drink
they're [ __ ] dealing with then you've
got like maybe an umbrella you've got
what and then you couldn't tell this
story at the Christian comedy club cuz
you said [ __ ] yeah I know
see and that's just the way I speak so
[ __ ] those people have you been going
out with runs easy a lot I've been out a
little bit with him every now and then
yeah he's great he's awesome he saw some
golfers drunk dude it is the funniest
thing in the world because he gets that
like 50 yards stare when he's talking to
you and one eyes going this way and when
I was going that one he reverts back to
like 1971 this goes right through young
goes back to 1971 Long Island yeah he's
like I mean like Oh cuz we went to the
jason Ellis fight yeah
and he's talking about how he would kick
my ass in a [ __ ] boxing match yeah I
was just like and he's just so drunk I'm
like I'm right here dude I can hear you
saying let me throw up in the car on the
way home oh yeah it was great yeah it
was great had to celebrate Tracy's
birthday that day yeah awesome awesome I
thought he's mad at me but he's like no
dude we just gotta get back to LA and we
[ __ ] gun did yeah oh and he was like
not in good shape no I wasn't there like
didn't you post like a video of him like
puking yeah I mean dude the best part
being sober is just waking up not
hungover
it's the best I don't know how they do
it I don't know how they wake up hurting
oh I used to get this we had it'd be her
ting to slap like two hours hurting we
sup like two I just grabbed his [ __ ] go
we're leaving I'm like oh no he's afraid
of his wife well it's her birthday you
can't [ __ ] that up it's like first of
all I'm sure that in order for him to go
there had to be the promise that he will
be back at a certain time cuz you know
when you're married I don't know man
with kids I don't I don't know anything
about it but I've heard when you're
married that you actually have to follow
through with what you say I've heard
that I'm not sure I do they are wardens
yeah oh yeah their job is to [ __ ]
keep a song with you kids
like if you get a get-out-of-jail-free
card for the night and then it's like
tomorrow's her birthday and don't you
[ __ ] me on my birthday and stick me with
two kids and also our reservations here
you got to do it and also he's got two
little rena zzs he sure does in and that
and one of them is steve as a young man
so that kid has got to be a [ __ ] ham
do you remember that night we were at
Steve's house and we were drinking here
does lemoncello
it was some party that he had and it was
later and we're all sitting up by the
fire it's I think was me you Janis
Antonio and Rena ZZ and we're all
sitting there and we kept throwing that
[ __ ] in the fire because it was so much
alcohol in it like it was like oh yes
floating and you I think you guys were
all smoking cigars and then one of his
little boys comes out and walks right
past us and as I kind of stand on like
half way to the tree house right next to
the pool [ __ ] pulls his pants down to
his knee
she's got this little like four-year-old
baby but and he's got his hands like
this and you just pissing all over the
place yeah that's what yeah yeah exactly
so we're like hey yeah and he goes
honest fine anyways we need to come back
he goes hey what'd I tell you about that
little buddy and he goes don't tell Mom
and he goes that's right you got it and
I knuckled each other I'll tell you the
best story I've ever seen about that kid
is we were we were in New York and we're
he's got a place on Long Island you know
was forever there from and in his kid
cat his kid was saying [ __ ] and and you
know Steve's brothers a priest and so
his brother instead of them like
scalding the guy the priest takes you
know Greg takes a little kiss on he goes
hey now yeah that's a grown-up word [ __ ]
is a grown-up word that grown-ups use
when they're angry so you probably
shouldn't use that word and it's so
instead of it you know like telling him
it's a bad word he said that's a
grown-up word they use when they're
angry the kids like kid gets it he's
like okay okay thanks Greg you know
thanks uncle Greg whatever and then the
next morning we're all sitting around
Ari Simone we're all there we're all sit
around having breakfast and at the
breakfast table and you know across the
room Tracey was pissed cuz the dog had
gotten mud all over the couch yeah so
she's a bad dog yeah she's she's [ __ ]
scrubbing the scrubbing the [ __ ]
couch and he said Mickey you son of a
[ __ ] like this and the kid walks up
stands between us and his mom and puts
his hands on his hips and looks as he
goes can you believe this [ __ ] dog
and we're just like we all lost it
because like he used it in perfect
context so you had to you had to love
the kid for just being absolutely
perfect it was awesome it wasn't gonna
be in your future she's gonna be a funny
one yeah she's gonna be a funny one it's
blocked call you blocked the call you
got a block never giving in the Chinese
one yeah that's so weird
Brian Hill got it too and then I got it
he thought it was me playing a joke on
him the new one it the new thing the new
is they use the first three digits of
your phone number and that's how they're
doing the robo call so if you see one is
always a month first three dates the
first three digits so you just just
block the call or I take the corners
talk to him as long as Popeye was gonna
say somebody was trying to sell me
something and I just kept going on and
on and I was like and I kept doing it
yes I take yes I buy yes very good
and they're like you know the insurance
ones the best when it's like yeah I have
a couple tumors but that won't affect it
this will you know you just keep going
and they [ __ ] they lose they're like
I'll hang up on you and take you off
they're calling somebody's like trying
to call they're like we're gonna talk to
you about homeowners insurance I'm like
you have no idea who you just called
yeah you're calling me to come talk to
me about Bagley [ __ ] chance
you got [ __ ] maybe a leaf blower I
felt my phone number god I used to live
in it your dog still alive no he died
like eight nine years ago oh but thanks
for the with the last time you guys
talked yeah no but my is your dog still
a puppy
no it's been 17 years I used to live in
this condo in Malibu back in the [ __ ]
late 80s and for some reason I'm getting
these phone calls now from ill tours
going do you want to put your property
up for sale and I just started going
yeah like what are you guys like what
kind of down can you give me and I just
have been taking on this rollercoaster
and finally I got a call the other day
in there we need to send the paperwork
over and I go I need a deposit
you know before I can sign any paperwork
and they went through this whole thing
and then this guy called me he was like
the president and some realty thing and
he's like is this so you know there's
nothing and I go [ __ ] you quit [ __ ]
call me and it was just like you got to
get back at a man you got I get I get an
email like you used to be able to call
up you're like I hope I know this person
hello
and I was like I don't know that [ __ ]
number I get I get on this email for
this financial firm somebody put my
email in so it's like this big financial
firm and they and they they put
everybody on the email and and it's like
this other one I got the other day was
for like this
eating you know that we're having this
meeting bah-bah-ba-wa and I wrote back
and replied all I go [ __ ] you guys this
company sucks the owners a dick and I
just did this whole thing and I wrote
back and then all these emails are
coming back oh my god are you okay and
this is like [ __ ] you guys yeah okay so
have some fun it's been a wonderful 2018
don't forget your Super Bowl ring yeah
fighting any final thoughts for 2018 I
had a baby and she's cool
okay cool baby that'd be weird for like
oh my baby so such a dick baby Tebow
final thoughts I didn't have a baby this
year and that is also very cool but
thanks to everybody for listening thanks
as always to all the people that have
sponsored us throughout this year and we
look forward to working with you next
year and please subscribe to our patreon
as well we'll be doing a couple patreon
in the next couple weeks so you can
always listen to us there punch drunks
patreon.com backslash punch showing
trouble and hey guys if you listen to
show could you follow us on Instagram
we're only got about 4,000 subs on
Instagram go to punch young sports on
Instagram follow Aaron final thoughts ok
so guys it's been a pleasure I love you
big changes big big stuff happening 2019
for punch-drunk we're gonna go big
bigger than big hey Sam yeah I wish my
dog was still alive I miss your dog guys
take care we out enjoy the holidays